Es ist eine der rätselhaftesten
Explosionen im weltraum denn diese explosion bricht alle rekorde
nicht nur dass die supernova
Etf 14-mal es 2014 mit einem nachleuchten von mehr als 600 tagen mehr als zehn mal länger dauert
als normal sie hat auch einen mysteriösen
Vorgänge rund, um den zu finden müssen wir in das jahr
1954 zurück wie ist die lage also bei etf 14 teil es jetzt den klick zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Das ist eine wirklich verrückte geschichte denn bei
Etf 14h es stimmt einfach gar nichts, im lask
umriss observatorien kalifornien wurde die 800 millionen lichtjahre entfernte
supernova entdeckt sie explodierte mit einem für supernovae typ 2 p typischen aufleuchten aber dann passierte etwas das eigentlich
unmöglich ist normalerweise
passiert bei diesem supernovae folgendes sie haben vor der explosion eine geschätzte 8 bis 17 fache sonnenmasse beziehungsweise eine bis zu
32 fache aber dann kommt es sich nicht
So super nova sondern die sterne stürzen zu einem schwarzen loch zusammen es sind rote überriesen oder selten auch gelbe überriesen
Die zu solchen supernovae werden oder eben auch zu schwarzen löchern sie kollabieren immer auf die gleiche art und weise
Wenn sie nicht so groß sind der brennstoff für ihre kernfusion ist aufgebraucht und ohne diese fusion können sie der
Gravitation durch die eigene masse keinen gegend rum entgegensetzen die kreation ist dann
so stark dass der stern in sich zusammenstürzt das heißt dass die durch die relativitätstheorie
beschriebene krümmung der raumzeit denn das ist die gravitation
zum zusammensturz führt die masse sturz aufeinander und stößt bei diesem aufprall wie beim zusammenstoß bei dem unfall wieder
auseinander diese explosion sehen wir als supernova was übrig bleibt ist ein neutronenstern
durchmesser zehn bis zwanzig kilometer also winzig klein der rückstoß der materie führt zum aufleuchten
Der gase rund um diesen neutronenstern für rund 100 tage bei etf 14h es dauerte es allerdings
600 tage diese supernova stellt absolut alles auf den kopf was die
astrophysik bisher über diese supernovae wusste und es wird noch schmackhafter die
helligkeit der explosion änderte sich in den letzten jahren ständig immer wieder wurde die supernova heller und dunkler etwas absolut unmöglich ist und
Es wird noch verrückter diese supernova ist quasi ein. Déjà vu denn 1954 cup ist sie schon, mal
wissenschaftler und wissenschaftlerinnen entdeckten damals an genau derselben stelle eine supernova und das ist absolut verrückt wie kann das sein ein stern der
Mehrmals stirbt es scheint nur eine erklärung dafür zu geben dieser stern ist ein
dinosaurier ein stern den es so eigentlich nicht mehr geben dürfte solche sterne dürften nur in der frühzeit des universums
existiert haben sie sind mit bis zu 130
sonnenmassen absolut riesig und können dadurch
mehrmals explodieren ihr kern bleibt lange unbeschädigt und sie kollabieren erst nach mehreren explosionen
zu schwarzen löchern vielleicht werden wir hier jetzt zeuge der entstehung eines solchen schwarzen loches und sehen vielleicht in einigen jahren an dieser stelle
gar nichts mehr außer einer
Gravitationslinse wie sie schwarze löcher bilden spannend auf jeden fall ich halte euch hier auf dem laufenden wenn er kein video dazu
zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann lassen wir hier ein abo da vergesst nicht dem
Genau auf die glocke hier geht es weiter mit neue gefahr mehr streuende schwarze löcher absolut spannendes thema
Einfach draufklicken dann geht es sofort los und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt